my name is lauren price i'm a networking
specialist customer engineer at google
cloud and today i'm going to talk to you
about the networking concepts for cloud
sql that are helpful to know for
implementation security and connectivity
[Music]
cloud sql provides a managed service for
mysql postgresql and sql server
databases
cloud sql offers many services like
backups high availability maintenance
and more and all managed by google cloud
each cloud sql instance is powered by a
virtual machine running in a google
managed environment that is connected to
the environment that you own and manage
by running in a google managed
environment this allows cloud sql to
abstract away all of the management
overhead to be offloaded from you the
user to google cloud
even though cloud sql sits in a google
managed environment google will never
have access to the data that resides on
the cloud sql instance
cloud sql can be deployed with two
different access patterns public ip and
private ip let's start by taking a look
into the public ip deployment pattern
a public ip is an ipv4 address that can
receive connections from devices both
inside and outside of google's network
including from locations like your home
or office
let's take a look at the access patterns
from different scenarios let's say you
want to connect from a client on prem to
connect to a cloud sql instance the
traffic will egress from your on-prem
network and access cloud sql through a
public ip address on the internet
if a client is located in google cloud
the traffic will egress through an
instance with a public ip address or a
cloud nat and ingress to the cloud sql
instance through its public ip address
if the client is located somewhere on
the internet that client can access the
cloud sql instance directly through its
public ip
any clients making a connection to a
cloud sql instance hosted with a public
ip must be allow listed through the use
of authorized networks
by default the allow list is empty and
nothing can make connections to the
cloud sql instance clients can also
connect to a cloud sql instance hosted
with a public ip through a cloud sql
auth proxy which we'll discuss more
later in this video
the other cloud sql deployment pattern
is through private ip a private ip is an
ipv4 that's accessible on a virtual
private cloud or vpc
configuring your instance with a private
ip is preferred when connecting from a
client with access to a vpc either
within the vpc or connected to the vpc
through a hybrid connection
privateip cloud sql is deployed using
private service access
private service access is a commonly
used private routing method on google
cloud that allows workloads in your vpc
to access google managed infrastructure
services privately
private service access is implemented as
a vpc peering connection between your
vpc network and the underlying google
cloud vpc network where your cloud sql
instance resides
there are two parts to the private
service access configuration process
you will start by selecting an existing
or allocating a new ip address range as
the private service access range
you also have the option of allowing
google to allocate the range for you
in this case google will automatically
allocate an ip range of prefix length
20 and use the name default ip range
if you're going to create instances in
multiple regions for different database
types a slash 20 or larger range is
recommended
next a private connection otherwise
known as a vpc pier will be created from
your vpc network to the underlying
service producer network
keep in mind that you only need to
configure private service access once
for cloud sql per vpc network and the ip
range you allocate for private service
access will become available for use by
all google services globally that
support private service access
let's talk through the access patterns
let's start with a client attempting to
access the cloud sql instance from the
internet
because cloud sql is deployed on a
private ip there's no way for public
clients to access the instance directly
now let's walk through a connection
initiated from within the vpc in google
cloud
clients are able to connect directly to
the cloud sql instance from the directly
peered vpc
additionally you can also use the cloud
sql auth proxy
if you are in a peered hub and spoke
architecture model and you're trying to
make a connection from a vpc that is not
directly peered to the private service
access vpc you must use a proxy due to
the non-transitive routing nature of
google's vpcs
be aware you can also replace appearing
hub and spoke architecture with a vpn
hub and spoke model so that the private
service access route can be advertised
over the vpn
finally for a client to connect from
on-prem you'll need to make sure you're
advertising the private service access
route over the vpn or the interconnect
if the vlan or vpn lands in the vpc that
is paired directly with the private
service access vpc then you'll be able
to connect directly
if the vlan or vpn lands in another
paired vpc then you'll need to use a
proxy to connect remember you'll never
be able to ping a cloud sql instance
you'll only be able to initiate
connections through applications the
respective database client or the cloud
sql proxy
let's quickly touch on some network
security related topics for cloud sql
deployed with public ip you can use
authorized networks to determine a list
of whitelisted ip addresses that can
access your instance
you cannot use firewall rules to control
ingress to a cloud sql instance
you can use the cloud sql off proxy to
encrypt all traffic to and from the
database using tls and to control who
and what can connect to your cloud sql
instance
so let's summarize the three most
important takeaways from today
cloud sql can be deployed with either a
public ip or private ip access pattern
if you want to use cloud sql private ip
you must create a private service access
ip range and a vpc pier will be created
remember this when it comes to routing
you can use authorized networks or cloud
sql auth proxy to determine who and what
can access the cloud sql instance
thanks for watching and look out for
another video on the concepts of
networking for google cloud's managed
services
[Music]
you